hello everyone as some of you know I on
Friday I held my 100,000 subscriber
celebratory stream and we have a nicely
chess tournament the tournament featured
over 4300 players after that we gave out
some prizes to ten prizes for to the
Amazon gift cards and two championship
chess sets so all the winners of the
tournament who were paid in full and
some of you have already contacted me
about the prizes of the giveaway I
believe three of you for the Amazon gift
cards and one person who won the
championship chess set so I will get it
like a couple of more days for you for
you to contact me and if you don't then
we'll figure out how to go about this
but Oh every time I have a giveaway
people were always successful in
contacting me so I'm pretty sure it will
be the same this time so for this video
I decided to show you a game by the
winner of my $500 arena it's the
internet international master from
Meadowlands Vinson throw tiles also
known as operas and unleashes and I
chose this game because it features one
of my favorite openings as white it's
the manga Rini variation against the
Sicilian let me just show you the moves
it's a spoof sorry sorry about that
efore c5 and a3 once I was in a
bookstore and I even saw an entire book
that featured the counter the Sicilian
with with the move a3 what's the idea
that after Knight to c6 white goes b4c
captures a captures and after Knight
captures the gambit pawn you go rook to
a4 I didn't really have a lot of time
nor could I afford this book but it
seemed like an an interesting idea in
the game Vincent doesn't go for this in
the game he goes Knight to f3 and his
opponent is also a chess player from
Netherlands Rick shipper I couldn't find
any more information about him
unfortunately but I think he's rated
around 2000 above 2000 so Knight to f3
we have e 6 and D for now so forget that
pawn black has misplaced night here on
before white will create a strong center
and hopefully we'll get some rapid
development and I don't know if you
remember that game I made a video about
it it was a game won from the world
blitz championship between Magnus
Carlsen and Nestor in our Kiev I it also
featured this variation the man Guarini
against the sicilian indian cost and won
that but you know that there was there
was a lot of controversy to that game
but in case you missed it i will put a
link to it in the description below
since it's quite a nice game before
inner kiev called the arbiter so d5 here
we have 9 3 5 and this is a common theme
in in this variation where white will
counter the Sicilian with a 3
but even when white tries to counter it
with the immediate before this Knight to
d5 is always a nice move and here black
probably wants to go something like
magnet knight back to c6 and after
Bishop to b5 Bishop to d7 captures
captures and afteri 5 black will still
be up upon but white will have the
bishop prepare and somewhat faster
development so it's not something you
want to maybe really go for in a serious
game with white if you're not really
sure in yourself but if you like gambits
and sharp openings then then you
definitely might consider this so after
Knight to e5 black played Knight to f6
we have Bishop to g5 pinning the night
Queen to b6 now I'm pinning and
pressuring that d4 pawn and here we have
Knight to c3 and Knight c3 is a very
interesting move because it allows like
to play Queen captures on d4 and now if
you capture the Queen you get night cat
force on c2 forking the Queen and the
king but of course white doesn't doesn't
have to capture the Queen after Queen
captures white can go Bishop to b5 check
and I don't know after Bishop to d7
black decided he doesn't want to he
doesn't want to play this so after this
might the c3 move black played Knight
captures on e4 and here we have Bishop
to b5 check
night back to c6 blocking and this is
move 11 and this is where the fun begins
here
Vincent retires plays rook to a6 and
this is this is quite a move as it
offers black a lot of options what's the
idea behind rook a six well of course if
you capture the rook pawn captures rook
then you get Bishop captures on c6 and
now you need to have to give up the
Queen with Queen captures Bishop or play
Bishop to d7 and Bishop captures on d7
this is checkmate
another thing after rook to a6 as you
can see the Queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go
the bishop is slicing all the way to d8
so only move you could play if you want
to move the Queen as Queen to c7 but
after point to c7 Knight captures on e4
after D captures on e4 now rook captures
on c6 Queen to a5 check of course you
don't want to capture the rook if you
capture Luke then Bishop captures on c6
will result with the same idea Bishop
blocks Bishop captures on d7 and then
black again loses the Queen followed by
checkmate
so here black would have to play Queen
to a5 check and after Bishop blocks now
black captures the bishop on b5 but now
comes C 4 and C 4 really doesn't leave
the Queen any squares you either have to
capture the rook and c6 and again give
up between or you can go rook to beat
Queen to be 2 but now comes Queen to a4
threatening all sorts of terrible
discoveries if you captured the rook
you're again getting checkmated so black
could try you can't if you capture the
rook you get Queen captures King moves
now Queen to c7 and it's mate in one
King f6 Queen captures on f7 this would
result in checkmate so after this Queen
to a4 move you can try Queen the be one
with check but again I have to remove
the King and after we capture now black
a white wins however he pleases rook
captures this is with a double check
King moves but again Queen d7 king of 6
and the Queen captures on f7 and this is
again checkmate so after this rook to a6
the best move for black would have been
to play Knight captures on c3 removing
the defender of
the bishop and also attacking the Queen
on d1 so here what would have to capture
the Queen rook captures Queen a real
Knight captures Queen on d1 rook
captures on c6 and now again you can't
capture the rook because of checkmate
black first has to make some room for
his King and F on my fate so first
Bishop to b4 check now can capture some
b1 and now castles and now best move for
white is to capture the bishop because
if you just move the rook then f6 and
you lose a piece so you do have to move
the rook with tempo rook captures rook
captures and now after Bishop to d2
special capture skin captures white
would be what would have a bishop in the
night for rook but black would be up to
pawns and they are to connect at once so
it's a roughly equal position but like
didn't - black didn't go for this after
rook to a6 he decided to play Bishop to
b4 pinning the knight on c3 and here
it's it's also a nice a nice trap that
white can fall into if white captures
the Queen now for example rookie actress
queen and now comes Bishop captures on
c3 with check King g2 now comes a
capture Sun b6 with all sorts of devious
ideas that rook is now ready to come to
a 1 so after Knight captures on c6 now
of course not capturing tonight but
Bishop to d7 and now the knight on c6 is
attacked and the bishop on g5 is
attacked so you do have to play
something f3 now you capture after pawn
captures night and now see capture some
b5 and here black would definitely have
compensation and the better game as he
would still have the bishop pair he
would still have both of his rooks so
even material while black is better here
so after this Bishop to b4 move white
decided that it was best not to capture
immediately but he simply castled here
here we have Queen captures on a6 as now
there really wasn't anything to do
Bishop captures on a6 and now Knight
captures on c3 so grabbing
a lot of pieces for the Queen Queen to
g4 and now comes h5 first kickin the
Queen away from g4 Queen to h4 and now
Knight captures on e5 d captures on e5
and now Knight to e4 as the bishop on
before was attacked
so Bishop to d3 now comes Knight
captures on g5 Queen captures on b4 and
now a 6
we have rook to a 1 kind of stopping b5
as if b5 Bishop captures on b5 we had f6
Bishop to g6 check 90 to f7 and e
captures on f6 do captures on f6 and now
F for preventing black from expanding in
the center also controlling the night if
if the King ever manages to move rook to
h6 we have f5 now guarding the bishop
and going for trying to break open this
structure black created so the rook will
be able to attack the King we have E 5
not allowing the position to get opened
Queen to d2 and now rook to h8 getting
the rock out of the way Queen captures
on d5 we have worked to f8 and here
after rook to d1 a rich Knipper resign
shipper resigned the game as there is no
move he can play the work this route
can't move as it must protect the knight
on f7 the knight and f7 can't move
because it's pinned you can't play any
moves with the bishop of course the
threat is making one Queen to d8
checkmate as the knight is pinned on f7
so and black could try something like
Bishop captures on f5 simply to allow
the roof to defend at the eighth square
but then comes Queen captures on b7
attacking the rook on a8 rook moves and
now rook after screen captures and after
Bishop to f5
there is no defense against Queen to d7
this would be checkmate
so after rook to d1 black resigned and a
very nice victory by Vincent Roth iris
also known as Oprah vase and unleashes
who won this very nice tournament like I
said that featured over over 4300
players so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I chose this one because I really liked
that mandarina variation it's very very
fun to play it especially in blitz and
bullet but I will also show one more
game by by Vincent here as it was it was
the first tournament I organized so it
would be nice to show again by the
person who who defeated everyone so yeah
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank david Flores
Gonzalez Jakob LFO Oliver thought love
Amadeus Kasich and Terence more for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here and I
will put the list of all the winners of
the giveaway in the description below by
name and also by the price they want and
also a link to my social media where you
can also check them out so yeah thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
probably with another game from the
winner of the arena thank you